l'espace ne peut pas être un far west
donc il faut une autorité d etat
pourquoi parce que aujourd'hui l'espace
doit être le grand sujet pour un
objectif commun de l'humanité et pour
cela il faut que les états y participent
d'une part notre part on peut pas
laisser des débris spatiaux se produire
partout il faut une autorité qui puisse
disons dans les orbites basses assainir
ce qui s'y passe donc il ya tout un
effort à faire de ce côté et qu'en
thaïlande lorsque jeff bezos s'ils ont
déjà leur tête dans l'espace mais ils
ont des pensées qui est parfois un peu
aventureuse campagne en main ce que dit
on sera sur mars en 2035
non il faudra beaucoup plus longtemps il
ya les problèmes de radiation il ya des
problèmes de vent solaire on peut pas le
faire de cette façon et je pense que
c'est là où l'état nécessairement doit
avoir une vision c'est que si on veut
aller sur mars il faudra une propulsion
beaucoup plus rapide et c'est la fusion
thermonucléaire contrôlée qui devra lui
des études aux états unis puis elles ont
été arrêtées
donc c'est tout un ensemble de
l'économie qu'il faut voir et je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec le directeur
général de
les actuels le nouveau joseph achats
bachère l'autrichien quand il dit il
faut que les états est enfin une vision
et une direction et en europe 20 on n'a
pas vu beaucoup cette volonté politique
et c'est à cela que j'appelle
[Musique]